you can be sued over Bank errors all the
time yeah if that's a if that's the law
then the kid that's drowning at the pool
should get charged for stealing and
drinking the pool water
you didn't pay for that
[Music]
so a resident
in Trumbull where do you think that is
Nick Trumbull Trumbull Trumbull
somewhere in Washington
jumble that sounds like Canada Trumbull
is in Connecticut
Canada Connecticut Washington I get it
have you guys ever been to Connecticut
never no is it pretty cool no I was just
asking you drove through it I don't
think I have is that New England yeah
unless you work at ESPN though a guy um
says he did nothing wrong I believe
while he is being charged with third
degree larceny after police say he stole
a bag with several thousand dollars
worth of tax funds after he is just
walking outside of the bank in May and
he sees it back and he's just like
I think I'm just gonna take this bag and
go about my day yeah and so he did bag
full of cash how does he knows tax funds
it could have just been a bag full of
money yeah you don't know he says he
thought it was his freaking lucky day
yeah that's what I would have thought
about 9 30 in the morning he's
whistling around walking it's a bag of
cash he sees a bag of cash he's like
leprechauns blessing is it like the
dollar emoji on the outside of like a
[__] sack like what is it things like
this don't happen in trouble exactly so
he he goes out uh on the parking lot he
sees something on the ground and there's
no one around so he's like all right I'm
gonna check this out I guess I'll take
it picks it up and sure enough it's a
bag filled with [__] cash and and
apparently
um an employee of the tax collector's
office had happened to be on their way
to make a delivery to the bank branch on
what they call Quality Street and he
dropped one but he was unable to locate
the deposit bag so he's just like yeah
where the [__] did I put that thing so
he reported the missing funds they need
to chop his arm off dude that's a
[__] that's a racket right there a
little bit don't they [__] handcuff
you to like things that are important
nuclear codes only oh hey Steve in the
article does it say how much money was
in the bag that's a good question
I think it's time for you to leave
larceny and theft
lotion is used in like rap songs by
Jay-Z grand larceny says nearly five
thousand dollars okay that's it that's
it they tripping over pretty small bag
huh
it was a [__] album be a knapsack huh
five thousand dollars in cash it was in
quarters oh it's in quarters
it was not important oh this guy's
strong at deadly yeah
what do you guys really think of that
law where like if the ATM accidentally
starts spitting cash out you're a thief
for taking it I think it's [__]
that's [__] because it's actually
shooting it at you but who's it
protecting though right that's not
protecting you should be like your honor
I claim uh Finders Keepers losers
weepers yes and then they'll be like oh
[__] that's a good one because you could
be super
over Bank errors all the time yeah if
that's a if that's the law then the kid
that's drowning at the pool should get
charged for stealing and drinking the
pool water
[__] sucking up all that water huh I
was not expecting you find these things
I'm like so amazed yeah dude how fast
you're drinking all the water
we're in here look at that yeah
save him we're trying to save the pool
yeah we need that water yeah same [__]
man there's been a time when I once got
money transferred out of my account and
I called the bank because I didn't do it
and I was like oh [__]
damn dude you're being siphoned yeah I
was like someone's identity theft me and
I was like I never paid this person ever
in my life it was 60 bucks man and you
know like yeah you're like 18 like
that's like that's a lot of money that's
like sixty thousand dollars right and
I'm like 10 meals right there oh I was
like 60 I'm like
dude I've been Bank heisted yeah and
then they're like Italian jobs sir we uh
that was a mistake on our end and I was
thinking
holy [__]
I'm set back there
I was like can I symbol bro Zildjian
right at the [__] end too this [__]
and I was like can I get 60 can I get 60
bucks plus interest because you know if
they hold your money oh oh you asked for
interest yeah opportunity cost you asked
for interest no he laughed he says Ah no
we'll fix that mistake for you right
away we only get interest sir okay have
a great day so we only get he just has
to clarify yeah only we make money
because they borrowed my money for like
a week I didn't know this for a while so
they brought your money as soon as you
put it in the encounter no they lend
your money yeah they sure it is Gangster
because when my dad passed in October I
was looking at my dad's accounts and he
gets Social Security checks right and I
think maybe like a thousand or Eleven
Hundred a month or whatever and then he
passed in October in November you gotta
check from Social Security and in
December another one came in and I was
like oh
I'm not trying to do anything legal I'm
just going to observe what's going on
yeah what's going with this like passive
income I got a little side hustle going
yeah yeah and I was and then in January
it goes 1100 debit another 1100 debate
oh they took it back yeah I was like
holy [__] because they knew when he
passed government will take whatever is
there should have just [__] spent it
I was like that's [__] crazy I didn't
know it can go like they could just pull
[__] out the other way yeah [__] was
crazy if you're walking by an ATM and it
starts spitting cash at you and you
don't immediately try to grab as much
cash as you can you're a [__] idiot
hey you're in the car you know what I
did these days that I'm pretty proud of
when I see a coin on the ground I don't
pick it up what why it's good luck not a
penny though I thought penny is good
luck I pick it up sometimes think about
all the bad luck you had today heads up
yeah it's for luck I pick up quarters
for sure because of parking meters uh no
I just go like I made it now give it to
the next person uh pass it along sitting
on your high horse over there did you
make it with your rich guy over here pay
it forward kind of guy people calling
you going like hey dude your doorknobs
are falling off your your ice machine's
all busted and [__] he's like I made it
yeah he's like I don't need that luck
give it to the next guy how about this
you're in the Caesars Palace and you see
a hundred dollar chip on the ground
that's different that's a hundred
dollars not five cents
you know I made it this way a thousand
there what if it's a dollar chip would
you leave it or would you keep it
walking a dollar yeah anything over 99
Cents bro I'm taking well every no all
right I made it because anything over 20
cents I'll pick it up because the 25
cent is very useful yeah 25 cents I
would trade all of my dimes for quarters
Jordan when you're at Panda Express and
they're like would you like to donate to
like children hospital oh [__] no die
whoa whoa when I go to when I go to
PetSmart you don't want to round up
never save the whales ever I always
round up if it's less than 20 cents to
round up but if it's like round up for
72 cents I'm like [__] no I'm not gonna
go home well I do a gift to charity only
when I know the organizers I only donate
when I'm trying to impress the person
who's ringing me up exactly if I think
she's a little cutie Cutie Pie yeah and
then I'm like you know actually I'll do
five dollars on that I'm like hey it's
for the kids you put your hand on her
shoulder
sick all right it's for the kids I I
trust like the the non-profit
organizations where you know the team
it's a small team you know where they're
kind of using the money and then like um
also direct to families like people that
need it like during the Maui stuff I
didn't go to [__] Red Cross [__]
those guys yeah [__] them yeah but the
subject of the conversation is Cutie
Pies what about Cutie Pies yeah they're
real cute he chose the cutest family
well there's a lot in Amsterdam but I'm
not in that game anymore yeah I donate
to them stand up you made it dude
standard guy yeah I wish there was a box
to like only donate to certain people
yeah if I like if I knew I was giving
because like my uncle like has diabetes
right I would love to give money to
diabetes research but just not him
it's like when you donate to like
starving kids in another country and
they send you a photo if you were like
can I get the photos first
which kid am I gonna die yeah and you're
like
um I will get
Terrance uh Rachel
we don't give any to Craig he looks like
he eats enough
um what about like adopting an acre of
land somewhere they'll never see how do
you adopt a lamb it's like you're
funding for the for cleaning the land
that's like the people no I better own
that [__] that's like the people who are
like it's like they they clean this part
of the freeway yeah adopt the highway
yeah how do we get in the business of
selling people Stars bro because that
seems like a [__] bro you can do it
right now hey comment below if you guys
want to [__] well yeah don't they name
Stars after you yeah but who the [__]
can ever keep track of that nah they
give you a whole [__] thing but NASA
doesn't it doesn't they don't add your
star to their registry dude they're not
like adding attack added to the registry
that you see but not the one that they
give a [__] about that's a real recipe
oh man I know dude I got some Stars I
got hella ex-girlfriends up there in the
sky it's basically the who's who but
just like astronomically remember that
they were you buy into who's who
absolutely
[Music]
foreign